it's a yearly pilgrimage up the
Himalayan mountains
more than 300,000 Hindus make the
journey every year to pray at the amar
Nath shrine in indian-administered
Kashmir but pilgrims and tourists have
been told to leave immediately security
forces say they found explosives meant
to target routes used by pilgrims we
were told that because of militant
activities and threats the pilgrimage
had to be cancelled we're very sad but
what can we do the military has now been
called in India has deployed at least
10,000 additional troops in the Kashmir
Valley a disputed area claimed by both
India and Pakistan fear of a violent
escalation led to panic among some
residents who began to stockpile on fuel
medicine and food the peace in Kashmir
Valley and I can assure you on behalf of
the team security force here this will
not be allowed to happen
there's also mistrust of India's
government and its intentions skeptics
fear deploying more troops could be part
of a broader plan to deny Chama and
Kashmir special autonomous status it's
an indication okay fine they are
concerned about the security of the
tourists and the yeah trees but what
about the security of the people in
Kashmir I think what message are they
giving to the Kashmiri is that they
don't care about them that they have the
absolutely no concern about them
concerns include the removal of a
section of the Constitution that gives
employment and land benefits exclusively
to residents of the Muslim majority
State for days we've heard rumors that
article 35 a will be revoked and now
that the government issued an advisory
for pilgrims and tourists tensions are
even higher people are really worried
since the late 1980s tens of thousands
of people have been killed in the region
and the recent deployment of so many
troops is causing concern India insists
it's a way to ensure the safety of
pilgrims but many wonder if the troops
will remain even after all the visitors
are gone
Katya Lopez Liu Yan al-jazeera